Crom created the space for us here's
what it will actually do yep so we
officially have six military branches
now and we're gonna it's the new
branches called space force it's gonna
be working along with the Air Force but
a lot of what they're gonna be dealing
with is gonna pertain to satellites and
knowledge and space oh yeah
the six branch of the US Armed Services
that's sick
yes force oh yeah and they're starting
out with 16,000 people in the first
group and everyone's gonna be
hand-picked yes oh yeah
703 billion dollars that's only huh just
so they can basically scramble
information no so he gets the space do
no no it's also satellite technology so
communications yeah they're trained to
basically level the field with what
China and Russia is doing oh yeah Wow an
robotics is the other frontier where
it's a kind of a race to see you can
come up with the best robots to find
that'd be cool if you're one of the
first that freakin part of [ __ ] space
force right it sounds so cool oh dude so
cool I wish I was part of space wars we
missed that boat humpy I know I have no
interest in going to space No zero none
you know what was the thing that Elon
must said you you can go to space Mars
Mars but you never he said that yeah
right now he's working on trying to
colonize Mars but everybody who's gonna
be going on the first trip
they will never be allowed to come back
why they don't have the resources to do
a trip there and back so if you're going
here there for good enjoy that one who's
gonna do that oh there's a bunch of
people I'm sure sign up for it I think
it's a bunch of rich people I did enough
food for the you have to wait on pods I
don't know that's a great that's scary
man oh I gotta watch this I'm screwed
guy was a real psycho man yeah of course
he just gets off on his mom's teeth in
your teeth are very some
I'll say that I saved that I don't spoil
I know I'm saying so this mom have the
exact same bottom blue yellow right now
that's so your teeth in her I was like
oh that's Brian calm down dude
you have worst teeth and I do you we
know this right wait a minute do you
remember when the studio over here come
on in the studio face you to use candid
come here right no show the bottom no no
I'll show you bottoms come on
we don't yell on crooked but they're not
cooking yeah they are and look at this
hold on take a picture of mine check it
out look at those [ __ ] things now
open your mouth a little bit bro
nope that's it oh yeah can you do it
yeah you got some issues
let me see we just put a side-by-side
chin and Brian's had work done well no I
don't say work I work you're clear
vice-versa
I work Invisalign for don't say like I
had worked on it's not you had what I
have a beautiful teeth and they're still
not good that's Jukes I stopped wearing
them at night I got to start wearing
them again I'm gonna go to candid for
real cuz I didn't like Invisalign that
much less need whitener there's just a
quick one with Bill Cosby why were you
guys able to watch this at SNL well yeah
Eddie Murphy returned yeah you like the
bug what just like the monologue
Jesus so sorry
ooh I hope Kelly at 6:00 wasn't that
amazing though right know what you Brian
online know he definite sit but of
course not um yeah everyone on lines
freaking out about it it was cool that
like Chappelle Chris Rock and booney
watch it it's just like yeah is all
right so Bill Cosby's mad on his
publicist but if you read this is a very
long one but it's actually funny how he
talks about Cosby but I'm not reading
that yeah oh come on
it's sad mr. Murphy you're turning into
a race thing you [ __ ] idiot yeah
he said that you're turning into racing
cause I get so black comics can't make
fun of Bill Cosby cuz they're black what
are you talking about what are you
talking about the guy the guy had 19 or
20 women come for that rug to me more
than that yes 60 what are you talking
about Eddie all Eddie Murphy said said
if you would have told me 30 years ago
last time I didn't live you told me 30
years ago Bill Cosby be in prison for he
would be a live at home dad one would
think that mr. Murphy was giving us
freedom to leave the plantation how
crazy can make his own decisions but he
decided to sell himself back to being a
Hollywood slave you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] who wrote this step
infected I mean these are these are the
dumb hashtag not funny SNL hashtag far
from finished
hashtag free bill cause buzz is very old
God dude he's never get out you see so
you can't make fun of a [ __ ] serial
rapist I guess because he's black and
you're black okay yeah and and you're
not and you're being what and Uncle Tom
or something get the [ __ ] out of here
what what a bankrupt thing how about
Harvey Weinstein talking about how he
gave women their opportunity first you
see this he was like I was the first guy
to give them their opportunity I hired
female directors before it was cool and
yeah alright did you got 90 women that
you this isn't Betty give them
opportunity yeah would you say he's
embarrassed you heard that video another
video the the recording of him begging
for that girl to come to his room of
course it was a superb recently it was
like one of the things yeah piece of
[ __ ] everybody here has a little coal
deepali
I don't know if is Nicole this is
something everyone sick dodged that
bullet your for now but you're with
although I I'm I have the new formula I
think like like kid I think Boston has
it I used to get sick every four months
no matter what and now it's been almost
14 months but it's only because I'm
sleeping I take naps and you know I do -
but - sometimes you know get set just
the word gets it just the word and not
sleeping and then you get it like my kid
you think about it my kids are
especially tigey's around snotty-nosed
[ __ ] these parents man who
the kids go to school with runny nose
doctor [ __ ] all over the their hair when
they don't do their hair and like how do
you not do your kids here and drop off
at school well [ __ ] that you dressed
like that in come to school how do you
keep them to school and pajamas in bed
at the [ __ ] are you doing yeah I think
it's coughing like maybe take the day
off why would I give that to you as a
gift